[Música]
el presidente de italia sergio mataré la
rechazó la renuncia del primer ministro
mario draghi el premier volverá al
parlamento para enfrentar un nuevo voto
de confianza luego de que el movimiento
cinco estrellas de la coalición no
respaldará un plan de ayudas por 23.000
millones de ellos analizados en minutos
después de meses de protestas en su
contra el presidente de ser y la ncaa
gotabaya rajapaksa presentó su renuncia
y lo hizo enviando un correo electrónico
desde singapur país al que llegó luego
de huir del suyo los manifestantes
celebraron la división e insisten en un
nuevo gobierno para salir de la crisis
económica
hubo marchas antigubernamentales en
argentina los manifestantes rechazan las
políticas de austeridad que se están
implementando para pagar la deuda con el
fmi y piden más ayudas como una renta
básica universal y un bono especial para
jubilados y trabajadores no registrados
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
yo soy maría sara calle empezamos en
italia el presidente de sergio matare la
rechazó la renuncia del primer ministro
mario draghi pocas horas después de que
el mismo draghi presentara su dimisión y
es que uno de los partidos de la
coalición de gobierno no respaldo al
premier en la moción de confianza que se
votó en el parlamento dicho movimiento
fue el 5 estrellas ahora mario draghi
deberá volver al parlamento el próximo
miércoles a que se vote una nueva moción
de confianza que determinará si el
gobierno actual continúa o no para
entender las consecuencias de lo que
está pasando en italia nos acompaña
francesco mancuso doctor en geopolítica
de la universidad de pisa señor mancuso
un placer tenerlo aquí en france24
empecemos por hablar de la importancia
de draghi en la estabilidad política
italiana porque el presidente rechazó su
renuncia y le pide que continúe que
tanto lo necesita italia
primero que todo buenas tardes gonzález
para todos ustedes italia al momento
necesita estabilidad política tiene
cerca de 20 mil millones de euros que
tiene que gastarse y es un envío de
ayudas de la unión europea se han creado
planes para esto italia necesita
estabilidad política necesita un
gobierno estable
mario draghi representa pues un hombre
que representa
institucionalidad de un lado y de otro
lado garantías fue el presidente del
banco central europeo famosa su frase
cuando le preguntaron para cuánto tiempo
la unión la banco central va a ayudar la
economía europea y él le dijo el tiempo
que se necesita es un hombre que ha
logrado crear un gobierno que
básicamente tenía como único partido de
oposición el partido posición de extrema
derecha hermanos de italia la posición
del movimiento cinco estrellas fue una
posición difícil de entender muy
complicada porque porque básicamente
en la noche italiana volvió a reunirse
esta gran comisión del movimiento y ya
de las primeras palabras en el pasillo
ya hay prensas que empiezan a afirmar
que el miércoles
volverían a votar una moción de
confianza al gobierno y los entiendo
entonces porque llegar a esto y
precisamente cómo se llega a esto a qué
se deben estas divisiones ya que el
primer ministro respalda a ucrania pero
el movimiento cinco estrellas ha
discrepado sobre el envío de armas a ese
país que otras razones existen para que
la coalición se dividan pues el primer
punto de ser en mi consideración es el
regreso de giuseppe conté giuseppe
contra el anterior presidente del
consejo fue eliminado con una movida
política del parlamento y de alguna
manera esta es su idea o su manera de
volver a ser protagonista de la de la
escena política italiana es una ruptura
difícil de entender sino por razones
típicamente políticas y personales
y un movimiento en movimiento cinco
estrellas que están en grave crisis hubo
ya una primera ruptura con muchos
congresistas que salieron y se unieron
al ministro de relaciones exteriores ex
miembro de este movimiento es un
movimiento en crisis que busca en esta
prueba de fuerza
relanzarse políticamente señor francesco
gracias por estar con nosotros aquí en
france 24
muchas gracias ahora hablamos de sri
lanka el presidente- gotabaya rajapaksa
envió hoy una carta al parlamento
anunciando su renuncia que era justo lo
que le pedían los manifestantes que han
protestado desde marzo culpándolo de la
crisis económica rajapaksa envió el
correo electrónico desde singapur
mientras que en colombo la capital de
sri lanka los manifestantes celebraron e
insistieron que el presidente interino
que nombró rajapaksa también debe
renunciar
en estas imágenes manifestantes de
thrill ancash celebran la noticia un día
después de huir del país y tras una
escala en maldivas el presidente
gotabaya rajapaksa
envió su dimisión por correo al
presidente del parlamento desde singapur
una misiva que será remitida al fiscal
general para una revisión legal y de
autenticidad
antes de ser aceptada formalmente horas
antes los manifestantes que expulsaron
al presidente por su controvertida
gestión de la peor crisis económica de
la historia del país evacuaron los
edificios pero prometieron no abandonar
la lucha
no vamos a quedarnos en este edificio
sólo queremos echar al régimen de
rajapaksa orar y gotabaya rajapaksa ya
ha abandonado el país por lo que no
tiene poderes el blanca así que hemos
recuperado nuestro poder y por eso
abandonamos el edificio antes por la
mañana la policía había hecho retroceder
a manifestantes que intentaban entrar en
el parlamento tras la marcha del
mandatario piden ahora la dimisión del
primer ministro
ramil y créeme sin jaque fue nombrado
presidente interino por el jefe de
estado que unió y pagar el pueblo de ser
blanca sigue protestando contra este
gobierno antidemocrático que no tiene en
cuenta nuestras voces por eso estamos
aquí manifestando contra estos
funcionarios que están explotando al
pueblo y créeme zynga prometió dimitir
cuando haya un nuevo gobierno pero los
zelandés es agobiados por meses de
crisis y de escasez exigen un cambio
inmediato y completo de la
administración del país
en noticias de medio oriente del
presidente estadounidense joe biden
terminó su viaje por israel este jueves
el mandatario se reunió con el primer
ministro interino israelí yair lapid
ambos firmaron un pacto para evitar que
irán o desarrolle armas nucleares y el
viernes bailén irá a territorios
palestinos y luego volará a arabia
saudita el líder de la casa blanca dijo
que hablara de las violaciones de
derechos humanos de los sauditas a pesar
de la necesidad que tiene en eeuu de que
ese país árabe aumente su producción
petrolera desde jerusalén nuestro
corresponsal federico cue barberena nos
da los detalles de la jornada
en el segundo día de su gira
presidencial por medio oriente' joe
biden se reunió con yair lapid y
coincidieron en impedir que irán
desarrolle armas nucleares aunque con
matices en las formas el presidente
estadounidense defendió la vía
diplomática como la mejor manera
mientras que para el primer ministro
israelí eso no bastará y es necesario
que irán tema una respuesta militar
creíble si insiste en su plan nuclear
esta posibilidad no fue descartada como
un último recurso por bailén y hasta
quedó plasmada en la llamada declaración
de jerusalén que firmaron ambos
mandatarios la integración de israel en
medio oriente fue otro de los ejes
previstos
lapidó invito a que más naciones árabes
se normalicen relaciones con israel
mientras que bardem prometió acercar al
estado hebreo con arabia saudita frente
a las críticas por aceptar reunirse con
el príncipe heredero mohamed bin salman
baiden dijo mantenerse como un defensor
de los derechos humanos y aclaró que no
ha cambiado su posición sobre el
asesinato del periodista llamado high
ops y del que la cia responsabiliza a la
corona saudí está relegado quedó el
conflicto palestino-israelí con apenas
una mención a la repetida solución de
dos estados que para baile para bailan
sólo será posible si israel está seguro
en la región pero a la vez se reafirmó
que jerusalén es la capital de israel lo
cual se sabe es inaceptable para los
palestinos la jornada se completó para
bardem con la recepción de la medalla de
honor del presidente israelí isaac
herzog un breve cara a cara con el líder
opositor benjamín netanyahu y una
participación en la apertura de los
juegos macabeos una suerte de olímpicos
judíos el viernes en bailén tendrá su
corto capítulo palestino de la gira con
una visita a un hospital en jerusalén
este y la reunión en berlín con el
presidente palestino mahmud abás luego
partirá hacia su última parada en arabia
saudita en argentina hubo protestas en
contra del gobierno del izquierdista a
alberto fernández los manifestantes
quieren que el dinero con el que
pagarían la deuda externa se ha
invertido en programas sociales y las
crisis económica del país podría dejar
una inflación anual disparada que podría
llegar hasta el 80 por ciento tal andrés
granadillo nos cuenta crisis económica
pobreza y desempleo es lo que enfrentan
miles de argentinos que se volcaron a
las calles para exigirle un cambio en
sus políticas al presidente alberto
fernández vamos haciendo una permanencia
en plaza de mayo ya que estaba en una
situación cada vez más grave con el 50%
de la población por debajo la línea de
pobreza aumentan cada vez a los
porcentajes de indigencia una inflación
en los productos alimentarios del 8%
porque acaban de cambiar
a la ministra de economía y no ha
cambiado nada
los manifestantes buscan que el gobierno
apruebe una renta básica universal y un
bueno especial para jubilados y
trabajadores no registrados además
rechazan las medidas de austeridad que
anunció la nueva ministra de economía
silvina batakis con las que buscan
cumplir los pagos al fondo monetario
internacional a que le deben unos 44 mil
millones de dólares los manifestantes
quieren que el dinero que financia la
deuda externa se destine a los más
pobres de argentina merece que el bolo
en realidad salga decir unificadamente
en trabajadores ocupados y trabajadores
desocupados
esta receta del fondo que no podemos
seguir diciendo a la mente ya que no
podemos ir a la góndola y no poder
comprar y encima cuando vamos a poder
comprar no hay abastecimiento de
productos como pasa con el aceite con la
harina muchas veces con la azúcar la
inflación podría acercarse al 80 por
ciento este año según analistas además
conforme en los últimos datos oficiales
la pobreza afecta al 37 3% de los
argentinos en noticias de la guerra en
ucrania al menos 23 civiles murieron en
un nuevo ataque ruso con misiles en la
ciudad ucraniana de vinicio en el centro
del país esto según las autoridades
ucranianas trabajadores de emergencia
retiran los restos de un edificio de
oficinas en busca de posibles
sobrevivientes el presidente de ucrania
volodymyr selenski informó del ataque a
través de una videoconferencia que
realizaba con funcionarios europeos en
la haya esto fue lo que dijo zalewski
ante los representantes de 45 países que
discutían los crímenes de guerra
cometidos durante el conflicto
este es un acto de terror ruso estas no
son personas estos son bastardos que lo
han hecho así que dos misiles de crucero
impactaron en el centro de la ciudad 20
personas murieron hasta ahora incluidos
tres niños y hay una gran cantidad de
heridos me gustaría que hicieran un
minuto de silencio por todas las
personas que fueron asesinadas entre
2014 y hoy todas aquellas que fueron
asesinadas por rusia en suelo ucraniano
y en nuestro cielo ucraniano
y justamente la guerra en ucrania farc o
las conmemoraciones del día de la
bastilla en francia los desfiles
militares que retomaron después de dos
años de restricciones por la pandemia
rindieron homenaje a ucrania y los
aliados de francia en europa del este en
el siguiente informe vemos cómo fueron
los eventos que marcaron la jornada en
los campos elíseos
son el símbolo del apoyo francés a
ucrania los obuses autopropulsados sobre
los campos elíseos un desfile del 14 de
julio marcado por la actualidad
liderando el cortejo los uniformes
coloridos atraen toda la atención los
portaestandartes de los aliados del este
europeo bulgaria estonia rumanía y
hungría invitados de honor saludados por
la multitud
estoy orgullosa de que estén aquí y que
sepan que francia está con ellos
es un símbolo fuerte para mostrar a
vladimir putin que tiene que detener
esta guerra inútil entre los asistentes
familiares y amigos de los soldados que
quieren verlos desfilar pasa en dos
minutos
tiempo de ver como la patrulla de
francia dibuja la bandera en el cielo de
parís
[Música]
míralo escoltadas por caza rafale las
fuerzas de disuasión aérea como el agua
que un avión de alerta temprana y
control aerotransportado
el hijo de esta pareja de bretaña lo
pilota sí sí es genial lo que está allá
arriba es genial
otros buscan altura o encuentran métodos
creativos para no perderse ni un segundo
de la acción uno por uno distintos
regimientos del ejército desfilan
defienden nuestro país así que pienso
que tenemos que estar aquí también pues
el más guapo es el más radiante no se
preocupen por nosotras lo veremos
enseguida uno por uno distintos
regimientos del ejército desfilan
4.925 mujeres y hombres marcharon a pie
bajo la mirada del presidente de manuel
macrón el dron reaper sobrevuela la
capital por primera vez tras ser usado
por las fuerzas francesas en el sahel en
la lucha contra los grupos yihadistas
sin embargo el mayor aplauso del día fue
para los bomberos
hola
la ceremonia terminó con los atletas con
la presencia de los medallistas
olímpicos de tokio a la espera de las
próximas medallas que se repartirán
dentro de dos años en parís
y luego del desfile de los deportistas
el día de la bastilla terminó con la
torre eiffel iluminada de colores en un
momento del azul y del amarillo de la
bandera ucraniana fueron los
protagonistas
el fondo sonó la canción estefanía de
calucho orchestra el grupo ucraniano que
ganó eurovisión este año
[Música]
así nos despedimos de las noticias
ustedes sigan con nosotros
[Música]